- [Instructor] The
entire field of economics
is based on the idea of scarcity.
And, arguably, we wouldn't even need
a field of economics, if there wasn't
the notion of scarcity in the world.
So what does scarcity mean?
Well, think about what does
it mean in everyday life?
It means that there's not enough
of something to go around.
If we're talking about scarce goods,
scarce services, scarce resources,
we're talking about
things where if there was
no cost associated with
them, people would use
far more of that than
there actually is around.
And in this video we're gonna think
about different types
of goods and services
or just resources and think about
whether they are scarce or not.
So a related idea to scarce
resources is it's opposite,
which is the notion of a free resource.
So this is something
that, you could argue,
is infinitely abundant or at least
in a certain context is so abundant
that it feels like people can have
as much of it as they want.
The more that one person has of it,
it doesn't take away from someone else.
And the reason why scarcity is essential
to economics is because
economics is the study
of how do you allocate
these scarce resources.
If there's more demand for it
than the amount of thing that there is,
well, who gets it, how
much of it do they get,
and what do they have to give up
in exchange to get those scarce resources?
But for the sake of this video,
let's just first make sure we understand
and have a good idea of what resources
are scarce and which ones aren't, and why.
So this is a picture of caviar,
which is essentially fish eggs,
and it's not easy to get.
The fish eggs are deep in the water,
someone has to get to them, and then
they have to package it in some way,
and they have to get it to your plate.
And so, do you think that caviar
is a scarce resource or a free resource?
Well, if it was a free
resource, that means
that we're just swimming in caviar,
that it's so abundant
that I could just have
as much caviar as I want and there's still
as much as you want and that everyone gets
as much caviar as they like.
Well, that's clearly not the case.
Caviar is a scarce resource.
In fact it is a quite scarce resource,
and because of that, if you want it,
you have to give up a good bit to get it.
This is a picture of some
people working in a factory,
and the resource that jumps
out here is that of labor.
And labor's interesting because it's not
as tangible as something like caviar
but it is a resource.
And one could even argue
that caviar on your plate,
some of its scarcity comes
from the labor involved
of getting it to your plate.
But here these are clearly, it looks like
these are gentlemen who
are putting together
some type of fabric.
And so, would you consider labor,
would you consider that a scarce resource
or a free resource?
Well, it would be a
free resource if people
were willing to just do as
much work for other people,
actually willing to do an
infinite amount of work
for other people, which
isn't even humanly possible.
And even is it was humanly possible,
people aren't willing to do that.
They want something in return.
And so, once again, it
is a scarce resource.
There's many resources that
are pictured right here.
You have this beautiful town
next to this alpine lake.
And so, some clear scarce
resources are here.
Many people would love to have a view
like you would get from
this house or hotel
right over here, but not everyone,
and many people would love to live there
because of the view, but
not everyone can live there.
So that is a scarce resource.
The water here is an interesting one.
I can imagine in earlier times,
if before there was a town here,
if there was just a primitive village
living next to this fresh water,
they would probably view
it as a free resource.
If someone was thirsty,
they would just go up
to the lake and they would
just drink from the lake.
They would not have to give up
anything to drink from that.
But now the town, it
might be a little bit more
of a scarce resource.
They might want to preserve
it for various reasons.
In order to get the water to your sink
in your house, there
might be some services
or goods or labor involved.
Someone has to set up the pipes,
maybe it has to be cleaned in some way.
Well, then it might
become a little bit more
of a scarce resource.
Air for most of human history
has been considered a free resource.
And even today I'd argue that something
like oxygen, at least on our planet,
is considered a free resource.
When I take a deep
breath (breathes deeply)
it does not affect your
ability to take a deep breath.
It does not take oxygen away from you.
Now is there an infinite amount of oxygen
in our atmosphere?
No. But for our purposes it feels
like there's an infinite amount.
Now if the photosynthetic
plants were to disappear
and all of a sudden oxygen
started to get diminished,
or if we were in a space
station where there isn't
a seemingly infinite amount of oxygen,
well then you could imagine a world
where it could become a scarce resource.
You can imagine a colony on the Moon
or on Mars or in the space station
where it had some type of economic system
to decide who gets how much oxygen.
So I will leave you there.
As already mentioned, scarcity
is the central idea in all of economics.
It's the reason why we even need
a field called economics.
And as you go forward
in your study of both
micro and macroeconomics, we'll be looking
at ways to allocate
these scarce resources.
We'll try to study what
people have to give up
in order to have access
to these resources,
and we will have models that will help us
understand what are the implications
for these different methods
of allocating resources.